تخيل أنك تتذكر كل يوم من أيام
حياتك بتفاصيل مثالية لأولئك الذين لديهم
ذاكرة سير ذاتية فائقة
الجودة أو hsam باختصار ، هذا هو واقعهم
[موسيقى
] أتذكر كل ما
حدث لي شخصيًا
منذ ولادتي وهي ريبيكا شاروك.
الشرط ، لذلك
اتصلت بها لمعرفة المزيد ،
مرحباً ريبيكا ، مرحباً ، كيف حالك ، أنا
بخير ،
إنه صباح يوم سبت رطب للغاية ،
هنا كيف ستذهب ملاحظة جانبية في هذه
اللحظة ، أدركت للتو أن ريبيكا
ستتذكر أن هذا اليوم كان  صباح رطب
إلى الأبد
حتى تتذكر كل شيء بتفاصيل رائعة
يمكن للناس أن يتذكروا ما فعلوه يوم السبت الماضي
ولكن يمكنني أن أتذكر ما فعلته يوم
السبت قبل 10 سنوات وماذا
عن ذكرى عندما كنت طفلاً
عندما كان عمري 12 يومًا كنت مستلقية
على مقعد السيارة المصنوع من الفرو في سيارة والدي
وكنت أحدق في
عجلة القيادة وفكرت
أن ريبيكا هي واحدة من 60 شخصًا فقط في
جميع أنحاء العالم تم التعرف عليهم
مع هافين  g hsn
طوال سنوات مراهقتي ،
اعتقدت أن الجميع
يتذكرون بهذه الطريقة ، اعتقدت أنه من
الطبيعي تمامًا
أنه لم يكن الأمر كذلك حتى كانت تبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا عندما
قرر والداها إرسالها
إلى جامعة كاليفورنيا
للخضوع للاختبار لمدة عامين
بعد ذلك  هذا تم تحديدها رسميًا على
أنها تمتلك h sam
نظرًا لأن الذكريات يمكن أن تتبادر إلى الذهن
بشكل غير متوقع في أي وقت من اليوم ،
فإن ذاكرة سلبية كهذه يمكن أن تجعل
العيش مع حسام صعبًا ،
كانت أمي تضعني في هذا الفستان الساتان المثير للحكة
وكنت أبكي لأنني لم أحب
لقد أعطتني هي وأمي لعبة ميني ماوس هذه
ولم أستطع قول أي شيء في ذلك الوقت
ولكن
وجهها أرعبني ولكن في معظم الأيام هتم هدية
يمكن لريبيكا أن تتذكر الذكريات السعيدة
واللحظات عندما تكون الأوقات
صعبة في ذكرى جيدة تجعلني كذلك
ممتنًا لامتلاك هذا النوع من ذاكرة hsn ،
شكرًا على الدردشة مع ريبيكا ، شكرًا
[موسيقى]
وداعًا
لك